nous sommes aubigny une petite ville
devant des 2000 habitants mais pas
n'importe quel habitant vous allez le
voir un sri lankais va s'attaquer à son
propre record lever la jambe plus de
9100 fois et il va souffrir
record du monde au lancer très petit
mètre cinquante bravo monsieur david
maintenant le record le plus court
regardez bien lu durant une seconde
en une seconde rémy bricka à jouer de
douze instruments
et à moitié dans les airs mais les pieds
sur terre le record de give her très
cher en équilibre sur le menton
fin du calvaire pour notre ami sri
lankais et record de french cancan battu
il a levé la jambe dit 1376 fois en six
heures 5 minutes et 55 secondes ici le
record à battre 2 97 m il consiste à
lancer un oeuf cru et à le rattraper
sans casser évidemment
[Musique]